depuis hier plusieurs milliers
d'entrepreneurs et de responsables
politiques sont réunies à saint
petersbourg pour le forum économique
alors pour tout savoir sur les dernières
informations de ce grand rendez vous
international du monde des affaires
on va te tout de suite retrouvé sur
place verra goffman verra bonjour alors
deuxième jour 1 de ce grand forum
économique de saint-pétersbourg bonjour
olivier oui effectivement c'est
l'ouverture officielle aujourd'hui du
forum économique de saint-pétersbourg
qui s'intéresse cette année aux
problèmes de société et du développement
technologique ainsi qu'aux nouvelles
réalités a imposé par la pandémie ducobu
19 et pour l'économie russe et mondiale
pour une centaine d'événements dont
certains à suivre en direct
effectivement sur ft france sont privés
dans le cadre du forum d'affaires de
cette année le partenariat entre paris
moscou sera évoqué lors d'une table
ronde aujourd'hui et le forum se
terminera le 5 juin qui tiendra à 2
dresser un bilan collectif de la
nouvelle réalité économique mondiale le
4 juin ça va être l'événement central du
forum c'est la session plénière avec la
participation du président russe
vladimir poutine
et aujourd'hui nous avons le plaisir de
recevoir l'invité spécial c'est le
directeur général de saint gobain en
russie ukraine etc oui antoine perrut
bonjour et merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et surtout je
voudrais vous demander quelles sont vos
attentes du forum est cette année mais
bonjour merci ou écouter le forum c'est
pour nous une occasion très particulière
parce qu'on peut rencontrer tous les
acteurs qui nous entourent par exemple
je sors d'une réunion avec un gouverneur
d'une région sur une future
investissements et du coup les décisions
sont prises beaucoup plus vite au total
sur le forum j'ai rencontré huit
gouverneurs de région
un ministre de ministres même je vais
participer à une table ronde
et puis en plus je suis très content de
pouvoir voir que les problématiques de
développement durable sont très
présentes cette année au forum
et justement comment votre entreprise a
survécu la crise sanitaire comme hank et
quels étaient les enjeux pour vous
pendant cette année à munich on a appris
la flexibilité un conte avait déjà mais
on ad'autant plus apprise non
globalement ça s'est bien passé pour
nous il ya eu un déclin d'activité au
deuxième trimestre l'an dernier mais le
quatrième trimestre a été très fort dans
le monde de la construction en russie et
le début de cette année aussi très forts
dont il ya un vrai rattrapage et même
une vraie volonté de développer le
secteur de la construction donc on
ressort de la crise je dirais plus fort
que ce qu'on est entré chez d'accord
donc pour vous en fait le secteur de la
construction en russie n'a pas beaucoup
souffert pendant la pandémie
alors il a souffert pendant la pandémie
il ya eu des arrêts de chantier des
halles chantier le tout haut mais
aujourd'hui on voit on voit un rebond il
manque encore des travailleurs immigrés
pour retrouver le rythme de croissance
mais d'un autre côté les les russes ont
plus investi dans leur maison
personnelle dans la rénovation dont il
est beaucoup plus de rénovation cet
hiver que les hivers précédents ce qui a
permis de compenser un peu les chutes
des gros chantiers des gros projets est
ce qu'il est possible peut-être de
comparer on peut la situation en russie
par rapport aux autres pays peut-être la
france je veux dire en termes de et
économique je veux dire en termes de la
pandémie ce qui a peut-être plus de
dégâts en russie ou en france par
rapport la pandémie cdc de comparer pour
moi ce que je veux dire c'est au niveau
du groupe saint-gobain legrand saint
gobain a eu une période un petit peu
faible au niveau du deuxième trimestre
l'an dernier
mais on est on est bien bien reparti
avec une très bonne situation financière
qui a été saluée par parle par le marché
avec une très bonne performance de
saint-gobain en bourse donc non je pense
aujourd'hui ou saint gobain
montre aussi que son organisation par
pays a permis des décisions plus rapides
parce qu'en fait il fallait s'adapter en
permanence la nouvelle régulation
le fait que l'on doit ne plus travailler
certains jours qu'on retravaille
certains autres jours donc je pense
qu'avec tout ça dans tous les pays
tout le monde s'est mobilisé pour suivre
au plus près les états pour aider aussi
les états dans la construction des
hôpitaux on a beaucoup investi aussi
pour construire des hôpitaux et donc je
pense c'est pour ça que je pense qu'on
ressort aujourd'hui plus fort qu'avant
la crise merci beaucoup antoine période
merci d'avoir été avec nous et olivier
je vous passe les paroles merci beaucoup
à vous verra et merci antoine perrut
dont le rappel directeur général de
saint-gobain en russie wragge hoffman
qui suit pour rt france le forum
économique de saint-pétersbourg